now there are warnings that the volcanic
eruption on the caribbean island of
saint vincent could leave 20 000 people
displaced for months
rescue efforts have been hampered after
another eruption caused
power and water outages the lasso freya
volcano first erupted on friday it's
expected to continue for weeks
the government says most crops and
livestock will be
destroyed let's get the very latest on
this uh let's bring in anisha moffat
who's
a volunteer helping to collect and
distribute relief aid and joins us via
skype from
st vincent naisha thanks for joining us
so you're living
through all of this right now just tell
us how desperate things are
um thank you for having having me
tonight
at present we are dealing with the ash
fall
from the ash venting um from the volcano
the last recorded eruption was around
4 30 today but we've been having
tremors throughout the day
the last report from the
seismic unit was it was happening every
one to three hours
the shelters are in need of water
food basic
living supplies toiletries and so on
many people had to leave without
properly preparing so we're trying to
lessen that impact right now yeah and
with
the widespread power and water outages
this
must be making life very difficult for
everybody
what about the aid what about the
requirements are you getting the aid
that you need and
how are you managing to distribute it
um right now we are working with persons
on the ground in the green zone um to
just
hand out whatever they have right now um
we have received aid from barbados
um i think yesterday sorry the days have
just been a bit fuzzy for me
um but i think it was yesterday that the
coast guard would have
come over with some material some
supplies for us
so the national emergency management
organization
they've been assisting in
ensuring that the shelters have
supplies for the next couple days
and what about you and your family how
are you coping how's your family coping
we're in the green zone our major
issue right now is the ash um so we've
just had to like
clean it off the roof every
well honestly whenever it's not raining
because as it soaks up the water it gets
heavier and it's causing um
house roofs and buildings to collapse so
we're just trying to prevent that right
now but
we are generally good right now and what
about the mood amongst people it must be
a
terribly traumatic having to leave their
homes
um having visited some shelters
you know people are concerned about not
having anywhere to go back to the
north of the island is covered in ash
livestock plants
the um the videos the pictures coming
out of the north of the island is
it's green indeed there's no better way
to describe it it's just green
absolutely just covered in ash what
about hospitals niagara are they
operating
how are they coping without power
we have power at the moment the
electricity services
were disrupted for a short while
considering everything we do have power
surges every now and then but for the
most part
we've been connected to power um
periodically we may lose and some areas
have been without power for a couple
hours based on
the schedule that the electricity
services would have sent out
um but we do have power and
um telecom so we're hoping that that
stays
for well we're unsure how long this may
last
and asha we wish you well in these
difficult times we do appreciate your
time
and joining us thank you so much thank
you